declining and our case fatality rate
here in florida is one of the lowest of
anywhere
um in the country uh particularly for a
state of this size about 1.3 percent
and i think part of the reason you have
that
well i think there's two main reasons
one is florida is laser focused on
protecting the most vulnerable
particularly uh seniors and long-term
care facilities
but also i think it's because you know
we've got a great medical system here in
the state of florida particularly here
in
south florida so when we reached out
a few weeks ago because the physicians
wanted to have more of the drug run
desevere
you know the administration responded
very quickly and we've had now
multiple shipments of remdezavir to
hospitals throughout the state of
florida
those physicians are using that and they
are generating better patient outcomes
now than was generated in march and
april throughout the country
part of that is just knowledge but part
of that is i think a testament to how
hard people have worked here
so even as we've seen um you know the
hospital census for covid stabilize or
decline in many parts of the state
that we recognize the great work that so
many people have been doing particularly
here in miami-dade county where we saw
the most hospital admissions
anywhere in the state but you know the
system has worked
uh yeah there's still capacity hopefully
we're not going to need more with the
covet patients
in the next coming weeks but people been
working very hard the state we've put in
150 folks just to jackson system and
we've put in hundreds more to elsewhere
throughout south florida
so we're here to help we're going to
continue to do it today is really
special
um because i think that this uh you know
comes on the heels of so much that
you've done in florida but now with
these clinical trials
we're really really uh uh looking
forward to what the university of miami
can contribute
uh to this very very important thing so
mr vice president
thank you for the continued support that
you've given the state of florida the
task force the president
uh all the cabinet secretaries um any
time we've called
uh you all have have strung into action
and uh
the people of florida i think understand
that but uh i'm happy to remind them
that and happy uh to be able to hear
welcome you yet again
here to the state of florida well thank
you governor desantis
and uh i know i speak on behalf of the
president and i express our appreciation
to you
to lieutenant governor jeannette munoz
and your entire administration
for the strong and steady leadership
that you've provided for the people of
florida
over the past four months but most
especially over the challenging days
through which florida
is recently passing and governor i
i've said it on all of my visits here
and in every conversation you've had but
i want to say again to you
and the people of florida we're with you
we're going to make sure that
the state of florida has the testing
resources
personal protective equipment for our
extraordinary health care workers
and also plays that leading role in
helping us to create the therapeutics
and the new vaccines
that someday we'll put this coronal
virus in the past
we are encouraged governor by the
favorable trends here in florida but
just like you i
i want people this state to know that
we're going to continue to make sure the
resources are there
to to ensure that anyone in florida
impacted by the coronavirus will have
the same level of care
that any of us we want a family member
of ours to have
so again governor thank you for uh thank
you for your leadership thank you for
the partnership that you forged uh not
just with our president and our task
force but with our entire administration
i am pleased to be joined
today by the commissioner of the fda
the fda cleared the way today for what
will be
the first phase three clinical trial in
the united states
89 sites across america with up to 30
000 participants will begin
their first phase three clinical trial
on a vaccine for the coronavirus and let
me just say uh
president and i are truly grateful for
dr hahn's
leadership at the fda it is remarkable
to think that
moderna that will be initiating this
phase three clinical trial actually
entered phase one back in march
and if memory surfs we uh we moved to
the first
first phase of this clinical trial in
record time
it was literally just a matter of
of the weeks after we received the
genetic coding for the coronavirus that
because of the strong work of the fda
and the urgency that president trump
placed on this that
we began to develop a vaccine and from
that point we continue to work at what
presidents called
warp speed to make sure that we have a
vaccine
every bit as soon as it is safely
possible to have
for the american people with the strong
support
of congress that's well represented here
by my friend of many years
congressman mario diaz de lart we were
able to secure
funding for uh for our vaccine project
10 billion dollars billions of which
have already been deployed to companies
because as you know governor we're we're
not waiting to create the vaccine until
it's
finally approved with both moderna and
pfizer and other companies we're
we're actually having them create the
vaccine
now and to have it ready
at the point at which we we achieved the
final approval from the fda that any
vaccine would be safe to deploy to the
american people
we have a goal of literally
manufacturing hundreds of millions
of doses by this fall and to have them
available by next year in fact
we're also in the process of procuring
over a billion
needles and syringes to be able to
deploy a vaccine to the american people
the president called it operation warp
speed and that's
that's the speed at which we're moving
uh to develop a vaccine but to be here
today governor to be here in florida
uh at a at a great a university
uh that has played such an important
role particularly
in in the midst of this pandemic and uh
dean ford i want to thank you
uh for the way university of miami and
miller school of medicine is
that step forward i know you actually
created a separate
covent hospital here for covet patients
and i
i want to agree strongly with with
governor desantis that it's been the
level of care
here in miami the university of miami
and all across florida that's
that's had the had the effect of
lowering the number of heartbreaking
losses that
that have occurred and so i want to
commend you for that
but i also wanted to say we we thought
there would be no better place among the
89 sites
across america than to come here to
university of miami
where in just a few short days the first
phase three clinical trial of a
coronavirus
vaccine will begin and i hope
i hope you take it and the whole team
here takes it as a great compliment
uh and a great statement of confidence
uh in the professionalism of
all of the great healthcare team here at
the university of miami we
we look forward to the results and
we thank you for the cooperation this
that's brought us really to this
this historic day a day when we begin
in earnest in phase 3 down the path
toward securing the vaccine for the
american people
so let me just uh let me close before i
turn it over to dr han
who will describe you the process
whereby we got here and what we'll be
looking to see
in the days ahead simply to say thank
you thank you again at the university of
miami
now thank you to moderna for the urgency
and
public spirit that this company has
brought to this effort as
so many other companies have brought to
the development of vaccines
and therapeutics i want to thank
congressman
diaz-balart and frankly members in both
political parties have made the
resources available
for us to meet this moment and
i also want to i want to say thank you
to two other folks
first is to governor ron desantis for
that steady leadership you've provided
for the people of the state of florida
you and your whole team
have been have been there for the people
of this state
i want to especially commend you for
your efforts
to come alongside people in in long-term
care and in nursing homes
it was here in florida that we saw early
efforts to
make sure that we had the testing that
we had the supplies
to see to our seniors i want to thank
you thank you for those early efforts
they were truly
an example to the nation and we know
we know save lives and we'll continue to
and lastly i just simply want to say
i want to say thank you to all the
americans who have volunteered
to participate in this phase three
clinical trial
all of us have a role to play wash our
hands
practice personal hygiene wear a mask
every time that it's indicated or where
social distancing is not possible but
as we sit here today 30 000 americans
have stepped forward all across the
country to participate
in the vaccine trial and we also have
clinical trials that are
taking place in therapeutics and other
vaccines and so to each and every
american who has volunteered to
participate
in these and other trials on behalf of
the president on behalf of the grateful
nation we say thank you
but let me urge anyone that would like
to participate
in this clinical trial here in miami or
anywhere across the country you can go
to clinical trials
that's clinicaltrials.gov and find out a
way that you can
do more than your part to help us reach
that day that we put the coronavis
in the past so with that i'll turn it
over to dr stephen hahn the commissioner
of the fda and i very much look forward
to our conversation with all the great
health care leaders
and uh and and thank you governor again
for hosting us today
thank you mr president thank you
governor desantis and looking forward
really appreciate the warm welcome and
my medical colleagues here who are on
the front lines taking care of patients
very much appreciate it
and thank you for what you're doing to
help us get a vaccine to the american
people and folks around the world
i want to second um what the vice
president said in terms of the heroes
here are the folks who are volunteering
to be
participants in the clinical trial and
they will help us get to the point where
the data are available to assess the
efficacy and safety of a vaccine
it's a true sign of the great american
biomedical research enterprise that
they're at this point
at this time after the introduction of
cobra 19 and the pandemic that we've
been through
so again just a terrific work i think by
by all americans mr vice president
you're right we all have a role to play
and
you have done more than your share
that's for sure
at fda we are doing um all we can to
support vaccine and other therapeutic
development
as you know we have issued guidance
to outline the data that we'll need to
see because we have great scientists
doctors pharmacists nurses at fda
who will be looking at the data when
they're available
for the vaccine to determine its safety
and effectiveness
i think it's really important some of
the components of that one is we've
specified
how many people should be in the trial
because we're looking at a floor
in terms of the efficacy of a vaccine we
specified that
participants from all walks of life from
all groups
particularly those who are typically
underrepresented
in clinical trials should participate in
this trial so we have a sense
of these results being generalizable
fda scientists in our center for
biologic evaluation and research
will not cut corners and we just stress
that
will not cut corners in order to
evaluate a vaccine
and although we have gone at significant
speed to get to this point
our job at fda and our solemn promise to
the american people
is that we will judge based upon the
data and upon the gold standard that we
have at fda regarding the safety and
efficacy of a vaccine
now the fda scientists who have called
the balls and strikes
they do this every day that's what
they've been doing for years
uh they're aware of the information that
we need and i know that the great
teams university of miami and elsewhere
around the country will be providing
those data to the fda
and then finally we uh we have a really
robust pipeline of therapeutics and
vaccines in the united states and around
the world
we're fortunate i think governor
desantis and dean ford you mentioned the
fact that we're in a
fundamentally different place than we
have been years in the last couple of
months with respect
to therapeutics but also the great care
that's being provided
and there are more than 100 vaccines
that are being looked at around the
world in various stages of development
and of course
we are have a number of them in-house at
fda and we expect at least two
additional to be in phase three trials
within the next several weeks
so it's terrific to be here um i can
assure you that fda is on the job
and that we will make the appropriate
adjudication with respect to safety and
efficacy
thank you thank you thank you
okay
no